[Music]
going with a blanket statement about
upsetting scenes that might occur but
not giving any specifics as to who it
might upset thereby providing little
more information than saying nothing at
all what happens when the wrong people
get powers
wrong people kids agent barry agent
barry may be the most complex character
in the series he takes agent ever to
task on a comment that comes off as
racist and then when he finds out she's
talking about kids he proposes
rounds as a solution and has to be told
i want this kid taken alive the sin is
not digging further into this man's
decision-making process damage control
could be a penn station so we're gonna
transfer at the next stop and head of
state okay bruno assumes that in all of
the tri-state area damage control has
focused its entire search on just one
transportation hub how can he be so sure
they won't already be at the next stop
and at pretty much every station that
leads out of the city as bruno and
comrade make their way from car to car
on the subway we can see these two
completely different windows have very
similar graffiti so similar i'm calling
someone out for plagiarism comron
somehow neither kills nor hurts anyone
in the subway car with his spontaneous
nora missions oh my god
i had no idea
kids i i mean older siblings that insist
on perpetuating the same relationship
dynamic that existed when you were kids
in classic con gossip train whether it
be gossip trains or just gossip in
general gossip is a sin although does
that mean i'm gossiping about how gossip
is a sin did i just break the fourth sin
wall in this video did save by the bell
the college years really only last one
season i need to know
speak us because because just vape
convenience this old people use
technology wrong bit that everyone here
seems in on goes on long enough to
wonder if even the characters in marvel
properties are feeling over saturated
with the ever expanding amount of
superhero content being made so much so
that they'd rather talk about use of
cell phone habits instead of kamala
being a freaking superhero
writers undermine all the urgency by
having kamala be pretty quickly
distracted by this heart-to-heart suit
reveal this qr code started off as a fun
little easter egg in previous episodes
but now i'm beginning to worry that it's
going to be spun off into its own series
yeah it's not like your best friend
could be a burnt corpse at this point or
need her help might as well have an
unnecessary moment where she stops at a
red light for comedic effect also unless
this is a low-key acknowledgement of
spider-man there's no other sky traffic
she would need to stop for and really no
need to stop for spider-man either you
know because of his tingle when the
coast is clear you guys head to the high
school and i'll call kamala why would we
go to high school because the only place
guaranteed to be empty on a saturday
unless there's a sporting event saturday
detention a local event being held at
the high school or the janitorial staff
gets a lot of their work done on
saturday but other than those things and
probably 10 or 20 more yeah i could be
empty presumably male 16 to 25 pakistani
or arab but you are describing
practically everyone here she is not
i don't have time for chronic quotes
excuse me
actually that was abraham lincoln boom
you've been lincoln trust me you don't
want a felony on your high school
transcript that would be weird yes but
you don't know that for sure i wanted
braces in high school till i actually
had them what can i say teens are weird
did you hear that i'm a boyfriend
and you're both witnesses why is miguel
did naki even need a person in the
closet to keep this ruse going this long
this room might as well have been filled
with rashid's yummy yummy chocolate chip
cookies you need a disguise okay marvel
you're very funny and i must admit that
i enjoyed this self-referential poke and
how often your production team thinks a
baseball cap would in any way be a
sufficient disguise but in this case the
joke here feels a bit like a hat on a
hat what are you guys wearing
what are you wearing the more important
question is how did kamala know this is
where she would find bruno and comrade
and if your answer is that nokia had
already called her then i will ask you
where on that costume kamal is keeping a
cell phone i feel like i'm being crushed
from the inside out my screams from when
i was trying to take a picture at my
local theater in 2015 and the heavier
than it looked pixar stand up fell on
top of me somehow make their way into
this episode i really need to get him
out of town
i know someone who can get him out well
that was so easily resolved and i'm a
bit confused is why we're using up run
time on this call instead of putting it
to good use with more glowy pad jumping
they tried to trick me into giving you
up zoe x mocking on their way into the
group for
reasons this is the plan is the plan to
dedicate a lot of time to detailed
drawings that ultimately cut into what
the show is trying to sell is a limited
time to set up the plan because that's
pretty much what's going on here and the
only reason it doesn't impact the show
in any way has to do with the writers
deciding that time has no meaning here
how did you get in here bathroom window
i went to school here too because
knowing how to open an unlocked window
and crawl through it proves you were at
this location on a daily basis for four
years superiors don't need chaperones
take it up with her guys clock's ticking
i appreciate comrade coming in to assist
with this sin but still the show has
time for this if the drawing of your
hoodie needs to also be labeled then
maybe just skip the drawings and go with
a list also you're in a defensive
position and not actively targeting the
dodc agents and feds well at least most
of you won't be just remember when they
all get caught later then instead of
making better preparations our resident
technical expert chose to [ __ ] around
with his skeleton the thing you're
supposed to break the glass with is
right there on the side of the box the
entire time i have no idea if this was
supposed to be funny or just make me
angry clarity on either side would have
been fine you and i can't grab as many
balls as you can this is for the high
school versions of you and me that are
laughing exceedingly long at this
statement and the real plan
is zoe okay so i guess using zoe's
social media presence in this plan does
make all of the sense but i'd also like
to reaffirm that her conveniently being
at the school so she could be part of
this makes no sense so you mean to tell
me you knew kamal had powers and you
didn't say anything zoe may not have
said anything but she did force us to
listen to everyone refer to kamala as
night light for six episodes do you even
like british bake off no no one
genuinely likes british bake off amir
and i'm positive everyone in the youtube
comments will back me up on this
no
not zuzu not like this as silly as the
next four minutes of home alone-esque
hi-jinx are and the idea that all these
highly trained damage control soldiers
get outwitted by a bunch of kids and one
random adult is a little insane i gotta
admit it's also pretty fun to watch with
that being said all of these highly
trained damage control soldiers get
outwitted by a bunch of kids and one
random adult my hands are tied people
go but he can multiply now multiple man
shadowing
me well just excuse me while i skip
along some glowing lily pads to get up
and over this scene
hey
guys come dance with me
[Music]
you know you like these moves aside from
bruno's disturbing lack of rhythm i
don't recall this dance being a part of
this well-illustrated plan all it would
have taken was one shot from one of
these shockwave rifles to end this
softball nonsense but luckily the dodc
trains their agents to blindly run
around corners what happened to my mom
comrade figures out something has
happened to his mother from nothing more
than kamala's desire to get help from
the red daggers instead of najma and his
amazing skills of intuition are never
used again in the series
i guess this soldier must have attended
school here as well since he's familiar
with the bathroom window entrance i
wonder if he was in the same class as
amir inside the school the soldiers were
firing at the kids just because they're
running away from them but outside they
just let komron get all juiced up
without firing one shot comrade will now
be a villain for the next six minutes
completely undermining the whole hat
situation with him and bruno earlier
that moment when all the supporting
characters try to make us believe that
our hero might not win this one
deciding to start giving your powers
names in the middle of a fight between
this and the commitment to only
hand-drawn plans i'm beginning to
question kamala's priorities
kamala was either very certain all the
agents would move out of the way at the
last second or she was very prepared to
kill a bunch of people right here
bringing a gun to a glowy light crystal
with ill-defined powers fight everyone
celebrates not being crushed to death by
cheering
instead of leaving the area so as not to
be almost crushed to death again as much
fun as the show can be diva is a
terrible and one-note villain i don't
even think tyler hayward would have just
started opening fire at children
especially not with a viewing audience
kamala's running crew survives this
because the luck of not being killed
instantly when the glowing rocks hit the
van was only surpassed by the luck of
these things deciding to suddenly start
expanding in a much slower rate and her
last moment she sent everything she had
to protect you that's what happened i'm
glad they cleared it up for me but this
exposition would have been more helpful
in the previous episode it would have
gotten us in there too just for being
exposition but i would have appreciated
it more get to the harbor
i'll buy you time did kamala drop a
detailed map of jersey city subsystems
that i'm unaware of how did she know
what would be under the ground here and
why does she just assume that comrade
will know how to get to the harbor
through this random hole she's created
in the ground and why is comrade so
confident in his ability to do this that
he slides right down into the ground
with no further questions
that was amazing i'm not sure kamala
needs this mask since her parents are
clearly going to do a [ __ ] job of
keeping her identity secret
kapow
kablam what'd you say when the jobs
girls are the best in jersey city lying
or shameless self-promotion take your
pick i share the same name as carol
freaking danvers i don't know who that
is he doesn't how is that even possible
outside of the fact that she helped save
the world his daughter's images of carol
plastered all over a room yusuf has
never once asked hey what's the name of
that lady on your wall but you sure are
and always have been
our own little
miss marvel roll commercials is what we
say here on tv sins but i might have to
start making an exception for marvel in
their pension for surprisingly long
credits on a tv show i for one think
that it looks much better on the streets
of jersey city thinking anything looks
better in new jersey kamala there's
something different in your genes like a
mutation threatening us with x-men
content instead of just giving us a
moment to be content with the story we
just finished whatever it is it's just
going to be another label marvel
sounding completely uninterested in
delivering the x-men content it just
threatened us with
marvel forces marvel's captain marvel
into marvel's miss marvel to prep for
marvel's the marvels because marvel
you will step up here and show me your
power and yes you will do so in front of
the entire class
i have an announcement all right let's
do forgiveness
oh my god santa here i know him
i just want to be sure that
you're being careful out there
i mean
be their monument be their angel
be anything they need you to be
or be none of it
you don't know this world a thing
this feels a bit more like you
no capes
[Music]
feel like i'm being crushed from the
inside out i can't believe you're making
this about you
we're with you
i'm with you to the end of the line pal
apparently there's such thing as bad
press and i don't like it what is this
there is no such thing
as bad publicity sweetheart
she chose you you were the chosen one it
was said that you would destroy this sin
not join them